my next guest is a very funny man whom
you've seen a new girl and the
neighborhood he's also the father of two
children a credit that inspired him to
create dads it's the first dad focus
parenting and baby goods company let's
say hi to the truly talented max
Greenfield what's up max hey I love your
quarantine stash it's a whole thing
11 did you try the full beard or you
just went for Tom Selleck
I went beard at first and then they were
like don't touch your face
and I was like itching the beard shave
this off so I don't get sick and then I
was like well I shouldn't shave it all
and then now I just have a mustache it's
awesome I love chips is gonna be calling
I'm into it well your kids are ten and
four now so how has it been locked
inside with them for the last four
months we've really gotten to know each
other and it's crazy though right I feel
like here's the thing I literally was I
started therapy up again in quarantine
cuz I was like I need someone to talk to
outside of this house and I will pay
them it's not I I literally know
something there was like I feel like
it's like a like like it's almost like
two different humans in one body like
with my two like it'll be like so great
and then all of a sudden it's just like
demons have are just coming out at me
and I don't know what is happening yeah
I don't know I like goes weak because my
daughter is ten and my son is four and
there's that's that's a pretty
significant age gap so there's not a lot
of things or activities together yeah
though a lot of it is like keeping one
at bay and then really focusing on one
and then going back and forth and then
you're a caught off guard when you're
with one and it's going really well like
you know the homeschooling with my
daughter
there are day most days I think it goes
really well and I'm like we're in a good
zone and streeting doing this and then I
learned
all right you're good you're doing this
I go over to my son and my son's like
and I go no we just had a good vibe why
you gonna ruin the vibe over here all
right well everybody at home max
homeschooled his daughter through the
end of fourth grade no easy task he
recorded some of those lessons and made
a little mashup can we play that cuz
it's awesome so how do you find the area
of the square okay so how do you find
the perimeter so basically how do you
find the perimeter of an irregular shape
so basically oh who found the
french-indian war so basically the
onions ain't gonna be cool like you
welcome around in high-heeled shoes a
quasi in a book what's the glossary so
um basically it's like the dictionary
but like much smaller how would you
describe his hairstyle I love dogs okay
so basically she got it and you just
didn't understand I guess so basically
like does she always start sentences
like that yeah she does and then we did
the video and and it came it was really
funny and and and people had responded
how funny they thought it was and I
think she thought oh I should definitely
I should like up the amount of times
that I'm saying so basically it's sort
of reaffirmed and gave her confidence in
that phrase and I have since had to be
like hey so we don't want to start every
sentence with that yeah and I didn't
want to discourage her and make her feel
bad about it but there was a gentle sort
of like let's find a different end to
when we're just talking about I don't
know anything
yeah well Siri on a serious note what
did you learn from teaching fourth grade
for a couple of months oh my patience
it was a real exercising Paige
do you ever find yourself doing the
homework and going I don't know how to
do this and I'm a grown woman know so
much of it I can't even tell you
there was like I got to a point where
because the beginning was just
completely overwhelming and then you get
into a group and you start to start
realizing okay so there's this math
assignment they like tessellations I
never even heard of a tesselation so I
told Lily that she's probably never
gonna hear of one either this is nice no
one will use this but you know like the
English and storytelling and some of the
writing assignments we really focused on
and I think we did a good job there are
some real wins in this and you got to
celebrate those well what am I your son
did he learn anything gee do any zoom
stuff of them you know you just can
focus on the one he's four-and-a-half
there'll be some significant damage to
him and and well we can we have time to
make that up whereas Lily's 10 and she's
really on the precipice of some
important stuff and if she gets choo if
she can get left behind right now and
we're trying to avoid that you know
speaking of being a dad though tell me
about this new company he founded dad's
yeah we're really excited about it you
know we are honestly I don't know that
I'm ever doing anything other than
hanging out with these kids and trying
to take care of them so we decided to
start a business out of it but it really
started a communication you know a lot
of this has started a communication
between me and a lot of other dads and
you know just reaching out with support
and and laughter and sharing a lot of
these moments and I talked to these guys
who would who had started this I had
this idea for dads and and I jumped
right in I loved what they were about
supporting dads and supporting his
committee and just actively trying to
get dads more involved
and really just having a product line
for dads that supports one another
hasn't really happened before I know and
that's what we have been talking about
and that's what we're trying to do and
you know we have a charitable aspect to
our company and and you know a lot of
our proceeds will go to a revolving door
of different father charities one we're
working with right now as a father is
called fathers incorporated that's based
in Atlanta and you know this is just a
real positive company and I'm so excited
to be involved that's so cool and so
it's a great innovative idea um I want
to show the photo from your press
release for dads custody and such a
great example of what really happens I
love that most people you know they make
their instagrams like a fake life like a
fake version of their life yours is like
real I think that's what's so awesome
because are they really is this a real
reaction is he really crying yeah this
is what happens if I try to get everyone
in a picture well man thank you so much
for joining us you're hysterical
it's I love you every time you come here
everybody might we were all talking
about it before you you logged logged in
oh you're the best I love coming on this
has been so great yes to your family and
all of our families we're all stuck at
home and this has been really hard and
relatively speaking for everyone in
their own world so thank you so much for
joining us and Max takes a so much sense
how your kiddos thank you because that
made me laugh so hard well dad's is
rolling out new products all the time
check out their website for more info
everybody subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going